let's imagine
uh two alien civilizations coexisting on
a planet what's that look like exactly
so i would say um
[Music]
i think i've got to get around your
argument okay yeah let's say that say
that on this planet there's just like
there's lots of available chemistry
and one life form gets um emerges based
on carbon and interacts and there's a
there's an ecosystem based on carbon and
there's an orthogonal
um and so it's planetary phenomena which
is what you i think right
but there's also one that goes on
silicon
and and because there's enough energy
and there's enough
stuff
that these light forms might not
actually necessarily compete um
evolutionarily yeah but they would have
to not interact at all because they're
going to be co-constructing each other's
causal chains i think that's where you
just got me yeah so there's no
so there's no overlap
in terms of their causal change they're
very limited
yeah so i think the only way i can get
away with that is to say right life
could emerge on a planet underneath
and uh okay lizard people under the
crest of the earth i think i think i
think we let's go to
i i think
that but look as you can see we disagree
so and i think sarah actually has
convinced me because of that that life
is a planetary for not the emergency
life is a planetary phenomenon and and
actually um because of the way evolution
selection works then nothing occurs in
isolation the causal chains interact so
there is a common there's a consensus
model for life on the earth but you
don't think you can place aliens
from elsewhere onto the can't you just
uh place multiple alien civilizations on
one planet right but i think
so you can take
two original life events that were
independent and co-mingle them but
i don't think when you're talking about
when you when you look at the
interaction of that structure it's it
it's like the same idea as like an
experiment being an example of life
right that's a really abstract and
subtle concept and i guess what i'm
saying is
life is information propagating through
matter so once you start having things
interacting
they in some sense co-mingle and they
become part of the same
chain
so
the commingling starts quickly yeah
proceeds we proceed to co-mingle quickly
right right so you you could say so the
question is then
the more interesting question is are
there two distinct origins events and i
still think that there's reasons that on
a single planet you would have one
origins event because of the time scales
of cycling of geochemistry on a planet
and also the fact that i don't think
that the origin of life happens in a
pool and like radiates outward through
evolutionary processes i think it's a
multi-scale phenomena it happens at the
level of individual molecules
interacting collections of molecules
interacting and entire planetary scale
cycles so life as we know it
has always been multi-scale and there's
i'm brilliant examples of individual
mutations at the genome level changing
global climate right so there's a tight
coupling between things that happen
at you know the largest scale our
planetary scale and the smallest scale
that life mediates but it still might be
difficult within something you will call
as a single civil alien civilization you
know different their species and stuff
but i think what yeah they can't might
not be able to communicate but you're
asking about life not species right so
what's the difference between
one
living civilization
this is almost like a category question
yeah yeah
versus species because it can be very
different like evolution because there's
like island like literally islands that
you can involve different kinds of
turtles and stuff and they can
so i guess what i'm saying is weird if
you look at the structure of two
interacting
living things populations
and you look in their past and they have
independent origins for their causal
chain then you would say one was alien
you know they have different independent
origins events but if you look at their
future by virtue of the fact they're
interacting their causal chains have
become co-mingled so that and then in
the future they they
they are not independent
um right right so that's why you would
even define them as aliens so the
structure across time
is two examples of life become one
example of life because life is the
entire structure across time right but
there could be a lot of variation with
this yeah so the question we're all
interested in is how many
independent origins of a complexifying
causal chain are there in the universe
see but
is the idea of origin
is easy for you to define
because like um
when the two when the species split in
the evolutionary process
and you get like um
a dolphin versus a human or neanderthal
versus homo sapien that
isn't there let me make a distinction
here um quickly so i think um sorry to
interrupt um
what we're saying i mean i mean i mean i
mean sarah we won that argument because
she i think she's right that um
once the causal chains interact and
going forward so we're talking about a
number of things let's go all the way
back before origin of life origin life
on earth on earth
chemistry emerges there's so there's all
these i would say there's probably
mechanistically
the chemistry is desperately trying to
find anyway get replicators the ribosome
kind of
was really rubbish at the beginning and
they just competed competed competing
you got better and better ribosomes
suddenly that was the technology the
ribosome is the technology that boom
allowed evolution to start
so what i was trying to why i
interrupted you is say that once
evolutionist started using that
technology then you can speciate and i
was trying to and i think what sarah
said was convinced me of because i was
like no we can have lots of different
chemistry shadow biosphere on earth and
she's like no no no
you have to have this you have to get to
this
minimum
evolutionary
machine
and then when that occurs speciation
occurs exactly what it's like dolphins
humans
everything on earth
but when you're looking at aliens or
alien life
um there's not gonna be two different
types of chemistry because they compete
they compete and interact and cooperate
because the causal chains overlap one
might kill the other one might combine
with the other and then you go on and
then you have this kind of
this average and sure there might be
re-speciation it might be have two types
of emerging chemistry it almost looks
like the origin of life on earth
required two different pre-life forms
the peptide world and the rna world
somehow they got together and by
combining you got the ribosome and that
was the minimum competent entity for
evolution
you